[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا مساء الخير انا ميسون
نواهد واقدم لكم اخبار الساعه كالعاده
نبدا بابرز العناوين
السعوديه وامريكا تودينان انتهاكات الهدنه
في السودان وتدعو طرفي الصراع للالتزام
بجديه وقف النار
والعربيه تدخل مطار الخرطوم وترصد حجم
الدمار الناتج عن الاشتباكات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع
حادث سقوط قوي للرئيس الامريكي خلال
مشاركته في حفل تخريج طلاب من القوات
الجويه يثير تكهنات حول صحته
تكشف عن وثائق مسربه تتحدث عن مخطط روسي
ايراني لطرد امريكا من سوريا
اوكرانيا تنقل الحرب الى بالقرود وروسيا
تهبط هجوما بريا نكاز على الحدود
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى اخبار الساعه طبعا
البدايه ستكون حول السودان اعربت السعوديه
وامريكا عن قلقهما من الانتهاكات الجسيمه
لوقف النار في السودان كما اعلن بيان
سعودي امريكي تعليق مفاوضات الهدنه بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع لعدم جديه
الطرفين وفق ما اشار البيان واكدت
السعوديه وامريكا انه هو بمجرد ان تتضح
جديه طرفي الصراع سيكون هناك استعداد
لمناقشه حل تفوضيه كما اشار البيان الى ان
الانتهاكات في السودان اضرت بالمدنيين
وايضا بايصال المساعدات لهم وحثات
السعوديه وامريكا طرفي الصراع على
الالتزام بجديه وقف النار
[موسيقى]
في الاثناء فرضت واشنطن عقوبات اقتصاديه
على طرفي الصراف السودان كما منعت
التاشيرات عليهم وشمالات العقوبات اربع
شركات تابعه لجهات عسكريه تغذي طرفي
الصراع بحسب وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه من
جهته قلم مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي ان
فشل وقف اطلاق النار في السودان سيزيد
مخاوف واشنطن من صراعا طويل الامد كما
سيزيد معاناه المدنيين
السودان
في السودان وقف اطلاق النار هاشون للغايه
هناك مخاطر كبيره تحيط بالسودانيين
ومازلنا بعيدين جدا عن التوصل لهدنه
حقيقيه وهذا ليس من مصلحه احد هذا العنف
يجب ان يتوقف ونحن نراقب ونعرف ان طرفي
الصراع انتهك التزاماتهما وهذا لا يجب ان
يمضي بدون حساب ننظر في خطوات يمكننا
اتخاذها لتوضيح وجهات نظرنا حيال اي زعماء
يقودون السودان في الاتجاه الخاطئ ومع ذلك
قال مسؤول كبير في الاداره الامريكيه ان
واشنطن لا تربط العقوبات على السودان
بتعثر المحادثات بين الجيش والدعم السريع
مضيفا ان افرادا من جماعه الرئيس السوداني
السابق عمر البشير في الجيش ليتم فرض
عقوبات عليهما كما اشار المسؤول الى ان
واشنطن تطمح ان تؤثر العقوبات على تصرفات
طرفي الصراع وتعملوا عن كتب مع السعوديه
للتوصل دائم لاطلاق النار في السودان
عرض امريكي باستئناف جهود وقف النار في
السودان بعيد انه مرهون بجديه الطرفين
النزاع في الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار كشرط
اساسي وفق ما اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه واشنطن اعربت عن اسافها من قرار
الجيش السوداني وقف المحادثات معتبره ان
الخطوه تصاعب وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
الى السودانيين
انه امر مؤسف انسحاب احد اطراف الصراع في
السودان اذ نريد ان يتوقف القتال وان تصل
المساعدات الى المدنيين فمن الصعب عليها
الان ان تصل الى من هم في امس الحاجه
اليها كالغذاء والماء والدواء لذلك من
المؤسف للغايه انهم اختاروا تعليق
المحادثات نريدهم ان يختنموا فرصه السلام
على محمل الجد ونحن بالتاكيد جدون في
المساعده وفي تسهيل هذه المحادثات
الخطوه جاءت بعد تبادل الاتهامات بين
الطرفين بخرق الهدنه الجيش من جانبه اوضح
ان تعليق مشاركته في محادثات جده مع الدعم
السريع برعايه سعوديه امريكيه بسبب عدم
التزام قوات الدعم السريع بجنود الهدنه
واتهمها بالفشل في الايفاء بالتزاماتها
كما راى انه لا معنى للاستمرار في تمديد
الهدنه في ظل الخروق التي ترتكبها قوات
الدعم السريع
اما قوات الدعم السريع فقد اكدت التزامها
بالمفاوضات مشيره الى ان الجيش تعمد تعطيل
الهدنه
على الارض ذوي اطلاق النار لا يتوقف في
مناطق متفرقه بالخرطوم والولايات
والوضع الانساني يمضي من سيء الى اسوا
ومع استمرار القتال تتفاقم معها المعاناه
الانسانيه تقول مفوضيه الامم المتحده
لشؤون اللاجئين ان نحو 150 الف لاجئ غادر
الخرطوم حتى الان اما في دارفور فاشارت
المفوضيه الى ان الوضع هناك متدهور هو ان
السكان يعيشون في ظروف صعبه جراء استمرار
الاقتتال
في سياق تمكنت كاميرا العربيه من الدخول
الى مطار الخرطوم الدولي حيث وثقت حجم
الدماج جراء المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع
اهلا بكم نحن الان داخل مطار الخرطوم
الدولي الذي دارت فيه الاشتباكات منذ
الخامس عشر من ابريل المنصرم دارت هذه
الاشتباكات وخلفت كثير من الدمار والخراب
ندخل الان الى صاله المغادره وهذه هي
الصاله الاساسيه التي كان يعبر من خلالها
الكثيرين الى وجهات العالم المختلفه نحن
الان داخل الصاله الرئيسيه للمغادره حيث
كان يقف هنا عدد من المسافرين
ويتجمعون لعمليات السفر واجراء عدد من
الاجراءات الرسميه للسفر في هذه في هذا
المكان كان يقف المسافرون
وتتم من خلالها الاجراءات الرسميه المتبعه
في صلاه السفر العالميه نشاهد هذا الدمار
وهذا الخراب الذي لحق بهذا المكان عدد
كبير من السيارات التي كانت تتوقف في مطار
الخرطوم تعرضت للحرق بشكل واضح جراء
الاشتباكات التي دارت منذ الخامس عشر
لنشاهد ذلك من خلال هذه المشاهد وهذه
الصور الحصريه لقناتها العربيه والحدث من
امام صاله الحج والعمره ومن الناحيه
الشرقيه ننظر الى
مهبط الطائرات الرئيسي في مطار العاصمه
الخرطوم بحسب ما نشاهد لم يتضرر جراء
الاشتباكات العسكريه ولكن عدد من الطائرات
شاهدناها محروقه او محترقه بالشكل الكامل
هنا هي صاله الحج والعمره حيث يتجهز كثير
جدا من المعتمرين والحاجين الى بيت الله
الحرام في كل عام ويخرجون من هذه الصاله
الى هذه السيارات التي تقف وتنقل كثير جدا
من
المسافرين الى الطائرات التي كانت تتوقف
في القرب من هذا المكان حتى عدد من
الشركات العامله في مطار الخرطوم نلاحظ ان
عدد من السيارات
محطمه بشكل جزئي وتوقفت بشكل كامل
الجوازات سفر وهواتف نق اله محطمه ولكن
هنا الصاله صاله الحج والعمره ما زالت
بخير لم تتحطم الجراء الاشتباكات العسكريه
التي دارت بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
الخامس عشر من ابريل المنصرم بعد 47 يوما
من القتال كنا معكم هنا داخل مطار الخرطوم
لقناتي العربيه والحدث عمار ابو شيبه
[موسيقى]
تعرض الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن لحادث سقوط
خلال مشاركته في حفل تخريج من القوات
الجويه في اكاديميه سلاح الجو الامريكي في
كولورادو حادث جديد يطرح تساؤلات حول
الحاله الصحيه للرئيس البالغ من العمر 80
عاما من جانبه قال البيت الابيض ان
الرئيسه اكثر بكيس رمل لكنه لم يصب باذى
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من واشنطن ينضم الى مراسل العربيه حسين
التوضي حسين هذه لم تكن المره الاولى التي
يسقط فيها الرئيس بايدن ما اثار تساؤلات
حول صحته ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل حول صحه
الرئيس بايدن
تحيه لك ميسون بحسب البيت الابيض هو تعثر
بكيس رمل يعني هو لم يكن يعاني من وعكه
صحيه ادت الى تعثره تعثر بكيس رمل ولكن
بطبيعه الحال هذا سيعيد تسليط الضوء على
عمر الرئيس وعلى قدرته على ممارسه عمله
عمر الرئيس 80 عاما ليس شابا هو يعني يترك
الكثير من التساؤلات والامريكيون يهتمون
بصحه الرئيس وبعمره عندما يريدون ان يصوت
ولذلك هناك سيكون هناك الكثير من القيل
والقال اذا صح التعبير حول هذا الموضوع في
الايام القادمه كان لافتا ان الاعلام
الامريكي فاكس نيوز مثلا عالجت الخبر
بطريقه سريعه لم يكون هناك تسطيط ضوء كثير
عليه ولكن بما من خلال ما نعرفه ما نعرفه
الامريكيون الناخبون الامريكيون موضوع عمر
الرئيس وموضوع صحته هو موضوع مهم بالنسبه
لهم وهذا امر يسلط سيسلط الضوء عليه
الكثير في الايام القادمه شكرا لك من
واشنطن العربيه حسين
[موسيقى]
فرضت واشنطن عقوبات جديده على الحرس
الثوري الايراني وفيلق القدس التهمه هذه
المره هي التخطيط لمؤامرات ارهابيه
لاغتيال مسؤولين السابقين في الحكومه
الامريكيه ومنشقين ايرانيين وشمال
العقوبات بحسب وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه
ثلاثه افراد وشركه تابعه لفيلق القدس وكان
النشط الايراني شهران بوصافي
بتدبير مؤامره لقتل مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي السابق جون بولتون انتقاما من
الضربه الجويه الامريكيه التي قتلت قاسم
سليماني ياتي ذلك مشاهدينا فيما نقلت
صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن مسؤولين
استخباراتيين ووثائق سريه مسربه ان هناك
مخططا روسيا ايرانيا عبر تسليح فصائل
مواليه للطيران في سوريا لبدء مرحله جديده
من الهجمات العنيفه ضد القوات الامريكيه
هناك نتابع
الولايات المتحده تفرض عقوبات على اعضاء
ومنتسبين للحرس الثوري الايراني وفيلق
القدس التابع له واشنطن تقول ان العقوبات
تشمل من شاركوا في سلسله مؤامرات
واغتيالات استهدفت مسؤولين سابقين في
الحكومه الامريكيه ومواطنين امريكيين
ايرانيين ومعارضين ايرانيين وثائق مسربه
كشفت ان ايران تسلح الميليشيات في سوريا
لمرحله جديده من الهجمات ضد القوات
الامريكيه بحسب مسؤولين استخباراتيين وفق
صحيفه واشنطن بوست الوثائق تصف جهودا
جديده واوسع نطاقا من جانب موسكو ودمشق
وطهران لطرد الولايات المتحده من سوريا ما
قد يسمح للرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
باستعاده المحافظات الشرقيه التي يسيطر
عليها الاكراد المدعومون من واشنطن الان
الوثائق المسربه تصف ايضا خططا لحمله
واسعه النطاق من قبل معارضي الولايات
المتحده من شانها ان تشمل تاجيج المقاومه
الشعبيه ودعم حركه شعبيه لتنفيذه هجمات ضد
الامريكيين شرقيه وشمال شرقي سوريا عبر
مركز تنسيق لتوجيه الحمله
الوثائق لا تضم ما يشير الى تورط روسي
مباشر في التخطيط لحمله التفجير لكنها
تبين دورا اكثر نشاطا من جانب موسكو ضد
الولايات المتحده بلال البجداني العربيه
سنناقش هذه المواضيع بعد الفاصل وسنتابع
ايضا في اخبار الساعه الرئيس الفرنسي لا
يستبعد التواصل مع بوتين ويتعهد بتوسيع
تدريب طيارين اوكرانيين لمواجهه روسيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى اخبار الساعه ينضم
اليه الان من طهران عبر سكايب صدق بوور
الكاتبه والاستاذه في العلوم السياسيه سيد
بور اهلا بكم معنا في اي اطار يمكن ان نضع
هذه العقوبات في هذا التوقيت بالذات حيث
يحكى عن او تقارير تتحدث عن وساطه
لتقربه وجهات النظر بين ايران والولايات
المتحده تجاه الملف النووي
نعم شكرا تحياتي طبعا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه دائما يعني تكرر هذا الكلام
دائما يعني بين ارونه واخرى هي تظهر وتقول
بانها مع الحل الدبلوماسي وان الدبلوماسيه
هو الاسلوب الامثل
الازمه النوويه الايرانيه وبالتالي نحن لا
نلمس منها اي مرضى ملموس ايجابي هي دائما
يعني تذكر هذا تكرر هذا الكلام من دون ان
تفعل يعني نحن امام تجربه مريره الحقيقه
يعني هناك ازمه انا اعتقد اذا هذه الازمه
لم تحال وهذه العقبه لم تزال اعتقد يعني
لا جدوى من اي تفاوض مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذه العقوبات ما رد ايران عليها
ايراني يتعودت يعني على هذه العقوبات يعني
هم يفرضون بالتاكيد يعني ربما هي هذه
العقوبات هي عقوبات شكليه يعني لا تستطيع
ان تنظري ايران يعني تستهدف اشخاص
ام عاديين او اشخاص ينتمون الى الحرس
الثوري
ولا جمل يعني في الخارج اساسا يعني نوع
هذه العقوبات والمحتويات هذه العقوبات
اساسا لا يمكن ان تخرج الى النور او تطبق
على هذا اشخاص يعني هذا الاشخاص اولا لا
يسافرون الى خارج الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وليست لديهم ايضا
حسابات بنكيه في الخارج وما الى ذلك
وبالتالي هذه العقوبات الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هي تريد للاسف يعني
تغازل اسرائيل وتريد ان تقول باننا باننا
حققت انجازا ما
صدق هذه التقارير التي تتحدث عن تجنيد او
مخطط روسي ايراني من اجل استهداف شخصيات
من المعارضه الايرانيه وايضا شخصيات
امريكيه وايضا القوات الامريكيه المتواجده
في سوريا
هل ستبقى الولايات المتحده مكتوفه الايدي
اتجاه هذه التقارير
امر التقارير تقارير اسرائيليه يا اختي
يعني هذه التقارير تقارير الاسرائيليه
واهتمامات خاصه لايران
لانهم كل ما ارادوا ان يتفاوضوا مع ايران
او يريدوا ان يفتحوا التفاوض ويحاولون ان
يستفيد من ادوات للضغط على ايران يعني
تاتي اسرائيل وتهدد الغربيه ايضا يقول
بانه يريد ان ينسحب والامريكي ايضا
حد الايران بان هذه الفرصه الاخيره
الممنوحه لها وبالتالي مثل هذه الاتهامات
انا لا اعتقد يعني ايران تقدم عليها
اغتيال شخصيات معارضه لها في الخارج هذا
الشيء غير وارد السؤال الاخير لو سمحت هل
ايران بوارد او هي منفتحه على اتخاذ
تدابير مثلا الخطوات لفرض بعض القيود على
برنامجها النووي من اجل مثلا تهدئه الوضع
الاقليمي السائد اقله خلال هذين الشهرين
انا اعتقد يعني الملف الاقليمي هو وكان
عقبه في البدايه يعني كان هناك رفض من قبل
الاشقاء العرب الخليجيين اتجاه الحدث
الملف النووي الايراني ولكن ايراني اليوم
دخلت مرحله جديده وفتحتها فصل جديد من
العلاقات مع هذه الدول وبالتالي انا اعتقد
الحاجز والمانع
الاقليمي قد ازيل وبالتالي انا اعتقد
ايران اذا اراده ان تتراجع هذا الشيء
مرتهم بموقف امريكي يعني يجب ان تبدي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حسن نوايا
تجاريه لن تعطي وعود ولا تنفذ هذه الوعود
يعني يجب عليها اولا ان ان على الاقل يعني
ان تفك قرار التجميل عن الاصول الايرانيه
المجمده في بنوكها وفي بنوك بعض الدول في
كوريا الشماليه والعراق واليابان شكرا
انتهى وقت المقابله اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
طهران عبر سكاي كونت مع مصدق بور الكاتب
والاستاذ في العلوم السياسيه
[موسيقى]
الى اوكرانيا الان فبعد الحديث كثيرا عن
بدء الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد يبدو انه بدا
يتضح بمرور الوقت حيث لجات كياف الى تغيير
تكتكاتها العسكريه من داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه الى شن هجمات متقطعه ومتفرقه
داخل العمق الروسي هجوم على الكرملين في
الثالث من مايو الماضي تبعته هجمات بثمان
مسيرات قبل يومين داخل العاصمه موسكو هجوم
لم تتنبه لكن بالطبع اتهمت من لم تتبنه
لكنها اتهمت بالوقوف ورقه
[موسيقى]
اخر سلسله الهجمات الاوكرانيه اليوم كانت
داخل بالجروب جنوب غرب روسيا والتي تقع
على بعد 40 كيلومترا من الحدود الاوكرانيه
الجيش الروسي اعلن انه تصدى بسلاحه الجوي
ومدفعيته لثلاث محاولات غزو اوكرانيه في
منطقه
معززتين بدبابات هذا الهجوم جاء بعد قصف
اوكراني مكثف في منطقه
السلطات المحليه في المقاطعه هذه التطورات
ليست الاولى حيث شهدت منطقه بالقرود
الاسبوع الماضي توغلا مسلحا من اوكرانيا
سبب صدمه في روسيا ومنذ ذلك الحين تتعرض
المنطقه المتاخمه لمنطقه
لقصف عنيف بقذائف الهاون والمدفعيه وهجمات
بالطائرات المسيره حسب السلطات المحليه ما
دفع السلطات الى اجلاء السكان من بعض
المناطق الكلوديه محضره من تدهور الوضع
من بل قرود الروسيه ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد عبد الجواد اهلا
بك معنا كيف يبدو الوضع اليوم في بالقرود
ابرز التطورات موضوع النزوح الوضع
الانساني ايضا للناس هنا
مساء الخير ميسون نعم سابدا بالوضع
الانساني الاقليم يزداد وضعه سوءا بما يخص
قضيه النازحين من المناطق والقرى الحدوديه
حتى هذه اللحظه ما زالت السيارات
والحافلات تتوالى من مضيق من منطقه التي
تتلقى حصه الاسد من الضربات الاوكرانيه
خلال الايام الاخيره الماضيه عدد الضربات
التي تلقاها هذاك الاقليم حسب الروايه
الرسميه تصل الى 215 ضربه تتمثل بضربات
الصاروخيه ومدفعيه وهذه طبعا المدينه
القريبه للحدود الاوكرانيه بحيث تصل اليها
قذائف المدفعيه بالاضافه الى المسيرات
والمسيرات الحامله لعبوات ناسفه في تطور
غير مسبوق منذ اسابيع تعرضت مدينه بلغراد
اليوم لضربتين من مسيرات اوكرانيا حسب
روايه السلطات كانت العربيه قد تواجدت في
احدى النقاط يعني هذه المسيره سقطت على
شارع وادت الى اصابه شخصين بينما المسيره
الثانيه تم تعطيلها واسقاطها بانظمه
الدفاع الجوي عدد طبعا النازحين يزيد الان
عن اربعه الاف شخص تم توزيعهم على ثمانيه
مراكز مركزين امتلاء بالكامل العربيه ايضا
كانت اليوم حاضره في احدى هذه المراكز
والعدد هناك يزيد عن الف ومن المتوقع ان
يستقبل
250 شخص اخرين طبعا حكومه البلاد تنظر الى
هذا الموضوع بضروره تنفيذه باعتبار ان تلك
المناطق تتعرض لضربات قاسيه وسيئه ومخيفه
كما وصفتها حكومه الاقليم وكما وصفها
القادمون من تلك المناطق طبعا الاضرار
ميسون لو سمحتي لي سريعا التنويه اليها
طبعا الضربات تطال عده مباني ابرزها في
حصيله الاربع والعشرين ساعه الماضيه تم
استهداف ثلاثه مباني سكنيه عاليه 14 منزلا
خاصا بالاضافه الى احتراق عدد من السيارات
الاتصالات وشبكات الكهرباء تم تعطيلها في
المنطقه ايضا طبعا المناطق والوحدات التي
تقوم بتغذيه الكهرباء لتلك المناطق ايضا
تعرضت للعديد من الضربات هذا الاعلان تم
رسميا من المنتظر ميسون اجلاء 600 شخص من
مدينه نحو مناطق في العمق الروسي اكثر
اماما امانا يوم السبت القادم تفضل شكرا
لك من مدينه العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد على
كل هذه التفاصيل والمعلومات
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الفرنسي انه مستعد للتواصل مع
الرئيس الروسي بوتين واكد ان بلاده مستمر
في دعم اوكرانيا من اجل تقويم هجومها
المضاد روسيا ماكرون اكد ان بلاده تعمل
على التنسيق مع الشركاء من دول التحالف
لتتمكن اكياس من الحصول على ضمانات من
النترو
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعد قليل بايدن
يقول لا نسعى الى الصراع مع الصين لكن
سنقف مع اصدقائنا ضدها
[موسيقى]
نتابع اخبار الساعه ايضا من هذا التصعيد
الامريكي الصيني حيث اكد الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن ان العالم يتجه نحو مزيد من عدم
الاستقرار بسبب التحديات التي تمارسها
روسيا والصين موضحا ان واشنطن لا تسعى الى
صراع مع الصين لكنها ستقف مع اصدقائها ضد
التوترات بين واشنطن باتت تسيطر على اجواء
بحر الصين الجنوبي التحركات العسكريه لكل
من البلدين في المنطقه ترمي بظلالها على
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بينهما فبعد ان رفض
وزير الدفاع الصيني لقاء نظيره الامريكي
دعا الاخير الى استئناف المحادثات الامنيه
الثنائيه قبل ان تخرج الامور عن السيطره
بحسب تعبيره البلدان يتبادلان الاتهامات
بالاستفزاز حيث يحمل كل طرف الاخر
بالمسؤوليه عن تفاقم الاوضاع في المنطقه
وعلى تعقيدها ايضا مستجدات قد تلقي بثقلها
على منتدى الدفاعي المسمى عقده في
سنغافوره بحضور الطرفين والذي سيتناول
قضيه المناورات العسكريه في بحر الصين
الجنوبي
اعتقد ان هذا امر مؤسف لكننا سنواصل
القيام بما نقوم به في هذه المنطقه وغيرها
وهذا هو العمل مع البلدان ذات التفكير
المماثل التي تشترك في القيم والاهداف
المشتركه لمواصله تعزيز حريه وانفتاح
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وبينما نلقي نظره
على بعض الاشياء التي تقوم بها الصين في
المجال الجوي الدولي في المنطقه والممرات
المائيه الدوليه فالاعتراضات الاستفزازيه
لطائراتنا وكذلك طائرات حلفائنا امر مقلق
للغايه ونامل ان يغيروا افعالهم
لكن السؤال الان ما سبب هذا التصعيد
الجديد القديم تقارب بين طائرتين امريكيه
وصينيه في الاجواء الدوليه فوق بحر الصين
الجنوبي كانت السطر الاول في تبادل
الاتهامات بين البلدين مجددا فالجيش
الامريكي اعلن ان الطائره صينيه قامت
بمناوره عدوانيه غير مبرره قرب طائره
استطلاع عسكريه لكن الصين عكست الروايه
ملتهمه واشنطن باختراق منطقه التدريب
الخاصه بها او انها من بدات بالمناوره
التي اعتبرتها استفزازيه تبادل الاتهامات
بالاستفزاز بين واشنطن طبعا ليس بالجديد
لكن قضيه تايوان هي الجزء الاكبر من جبل
الجليد والذي اججج الوضع بين الطرفين
فالجزيره الصغيره مشاهدينا ما تزال تحتمي
بظل واشنطن خوفا طبعا من اي غزو صيني
محتمل ويظل دعم واشنطن التي هي اهم شريك
وممرر للتايوان مثيرا لحفيظه بكين التي
تصر على مبدا الصين الواحده
التدريب العسكري من الجيش الامريكي ويتم
تزويدها مؤخرا بمسيارات وتكنولوجيا متقدمه
باتت تحاكيها وتدخل في صناعتها محليا
واشنطن لم تكتفي بدعم صيفيه عسكريا فلم
امتد ذلك ليشمل الجوانب التجاريه ايضا
سينضم الي من دبي الان الصحفي الصينيه
الهامليين سيد الهام اهلا بكم معنا لماذا
هذا الرفض للقاء وزير الدفاع الامريكي الا
تتخوف الصين من ان تنزلق الامور الى ما هو
اخطر وهذا متحدث عنه
نعم اول شيء شكرا جزيلا لدعوتكم الكريمه
في الحقيقه سمعنا من تقرير السابق عن
تصريحها من قبل وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
بان اهم هذا الامر مؤسف ولكن هذا الاساس
يعود الى سببين السبب سطحي طبعا لطرد
الجانب الامريكي
عقبات على وزير الدفاع الصيني سيد في
شامبو في الحقيقه يعني
اللقاء بين وزير الصيني
المعرضه للعقوبات ووزير الدفاع الامريكي
هذا امر غير عقلاني وغير محترم
بالنسبه للحكومه الصينيه ولكن هذا السبب
السطحيه فقط السبب الجدري هو الاعمال
الاستزازيه من قبل الجيش الامريكي وخاصه
الطيران السيد العام ما الذي يعيد الصين
الى استئناف المحادثات وخاصه الامنيه مع
الجانب الامريكي ما هي الشروط الصين
الحقيقه شروط الصين واضحه جدا اول شيء
التعبير عن الاحترام الاساسي لسياده الصين
واراضيها وخاصه
المراجعه فيما في قضيه التايوان الصينيه
في الحقيقه عندما بحثنا هناك تدريبات
عسكريه خلال زياره المنزل فلوسي الى جزيره
تايوان هذا يعبر عن عزم الصيني وخاصه في
المجال العسكري لذلك هل ما يجري بين الصين
والولايات المتحده هو تنافس او صراع
بنسبه الى منطقه اسيا الباسيفيك من الممكن
منافسه ولكن بنسبه الى قضيه تايوان اذا
تدخل الجيش الامريكي بشكل مباشر وسيكون
هناك صراع بالتاكيد هذا لا شك بذلك لانك
حيوان غير قابله للمفاوضات باي شكل من
الاشكال لذلك يعني الان هناك فقط تدريبات
الشروط الجيش التايواني من قبل الجانب
الامريكي ولكن اذا هناك وجود عسكري بشكل
حقيقي من قبل الولايات المتحده على جزيره
تايوان فهذه ثوره واضح او حتى ممكن اقول
هذا جعلان عن الحرب من الجانب الولايات
المتحده الى الصين ففي هذا الحال يكون
هناك اي احتمال من الاحتمالات بين الصين
والاولايات المتحده لكن نستبعد عن
العزم او الرقبه الولايات المتحده في وجود
عسكري لجزيره تاي وان لان هذا الحقيقه
بعيد عن المصالح الجوهريه فتتخيل اذا
الحملات طيران صينيه يقترب من كاليفورنيا
فماذا سيحدث نفس الشيء
الصحفي الصيني كنت معي من دبي
[موسيقى]
حقيقه المشاهدين هناك صراع اخر لواشنطن
لكن مع جاره بكين اي كوريا الشماليه وذلك
حول تجاربها النبويه والتي كان اخرها
اطلاق قمر تجسس عسكري لمراقبه الانشطه
الامريكيه العسكريه في المنطقه حيث تكثف
واشنطن من تواجدها مع اليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه لمواجهه ما يصفونه باستفزازات
ورغم فشل عمليه الاطلاق الا ان واشنطن
بانت هذه التجربه وقالت
استخدمت التكنولوجيا صواريخ البالستيه
المحظوره ما يزيد التوترات بمنطقه شبه
الجزيره الكوريه ويهدد بزعزعه الامن في
المنطقه وخارجها
ومع ذلك اتهمت الشقيقه القويه للزعيم
الكوريه الشمالي كيم جونغ اون الولايات
المتحده بالتصرف مثل العصابات لانتقادها
فشل بلادها في عمليه الاطلاق وبررت فشل
عمليه الاطلاق بان الصاروخ فقد قوه الدفع
بعد مرحله انفصال وتحطم في المياه قباله
الساحل الغربي لشبه الجزيره الكوريه
وتعهدت باعاده التجربه بشكل ناجح قريبا
كما قالت كيميو جونغ ان جهود بلادها
لامتلاك قدرات استطلاع في الفضاء هي
ممارسه مشروعه لحقها السيادي
[موسيقى]
لم يكن هذا كل شيء قصيره نحو البيت الابيض
داخل الحزب الجمهوري على اشده هناك مرشحان
اولهما من صوت كارولينا وهي نكهه للحاكمه
السابقه للولايه والممثله السابقه
للولايات المتحده في الامم المتحده اثناء
فتره حكم ترامب تنيهما عضو مجلس الشيوخ
توم سكوت وهو العضو الجمهوري الوحيد في
المجلس من اصول افريقيه لدينا ايضا صديق
ترامب بالامس ونائبه حينما كان رئيسا وهو
الذي من المتوقع ان يطلق حملته الرئاسيه
الاسبوع المقبل بخطاب في ولايه ايوا لكن
ما حدود المترشحين عن حزب الجمهوري
لمواجهه الرئيس جو بايدن في السباق نحو
البيت الابيض فوافقا لاخر استطلاع راي
اجرته شبكه سيانا الاسبوع الماضي حل ترامب
في المرتبه الاولى بثلاثه وخمسين بالمئه
بينما جاء ديسانتس ثانيا بسته وعشرين
بالمئه وحصل كل من مايك تنسى
تفضيلات الناخبين الجمهوريين ما يعني ان
السباق ربما ينحصر بين ترامب وديسنتس حتى
الان سنتابع هذا الموضوع ونناقشه معنى من
واشنطن الخبيث الشؤون
الامريكيهام وايضا معنا من واشنطن ايضا
ضيفنا من فلوريدا توم حرب مدير التحالف
الامريكي الشرق اوسطيه اهلا بكما سيد توم
سابدا معك خمس مرشحين عن الحزب الجمهوريه
الا يشكل هذا ضعفا في الانتخابات
الامريكيه
اولا مرحبا لك والضيف الكريم ايريك
وللمشاهدين الكرام لا بالعكس تعدد
المرشحين والمتنافسين يعني تعدد الافكار
ابراز افكار جديده على الساحه الامريكيه
ضمن الحزب الجمهوري وعند الحزب الديمقراطي
هنالك ثلاث مرشحين اليوم ولكن الحزب
الديمقراطي ام الرئيس بايدن اما المكنه
الانتخابيه رفضوا الاعتراف بالمرشحين
الاثنين بالحزب عنده وانما بالحزب
الجمهوري انا بتصور تعدد المرشحين تعدد
الافكار تعدد طرح ما يناسب الحزب الجمهوري
وما يناسب امريكا نذهب الى السيد اريك
لنعرف منه حقيقه لماذا ليس هناك غير مرشح
واحد للعلن وهو الرئيس جو بايدن عند
الديمقراطيين سيد اريك
في حقيقه الامر كان هناك اكثر من مرشح
واحد من من الذين تقدموا للانتخابات
الخاصه بالحزب الديمقراطي
وهناك ايضا وهناك
روبرت الذي كان من احد المرشحين
لكنهم لا ينظر اليهم على انهم قد يكونوا
بنفس قدر المنافسه مع جو بايدن لكن السبب
الذي لا نرى اعدادا كبيره من المرشحين
الاخرين الديمقراطيين لان هؤلاء الاخيرين
كانوا قد اعتبروا ان رئيسهم جو بايدن قد
يكون هو المرشح الامثل ولهذا السبب فان
الحزب الديمقراطي اعترف واقر بان الرئيس
يستحقه فتره اضافيه فتره
حكم اضافيه في الولايات المتحده
في اخبارنا قبل ان نناقش هذا الموضوع معكم
يبدو حتى الان الاوفر حظا هو الرئيس ترامب
ولكن هناك معضله وهو موضوع من عدم اليقين
القانوني بسبب الملاحقات القضائيه هذا لا
يشكل خطرا على الحزب الجمهوري بشكل عام
وعلى الرئيس ترامب بحال هو الذي فا
الجمهوريين ليترشح الى الانتخابات
الامريكيه
الوضع القانوني للرئيس ترامب هو ملاحقته
منذ 2016 عندما اعلن ترشيحه وتبين الراي
العام الامريكي بعد سنتين من ترشيحه انه
هنالك
بين الحزب الديمقراطي واجهزه في الولايات
المتحده لاحباط الرئيس ترامب في ذلك الوقت
2020 كمان لقينا نفس الشيء فلذلك الامر
الشعب الامريكي لا يعتبر بان هذه
المحاكمات عادله هذا محاكمات تتصبح مثل
بلاد الماج جمهوريات الموز اما عند الحزب
الديمقراطي في الرئيس بايدن عليه هنالك
ملاحقات قانونيه وضايفك منذ قليل تكلم
بانه عند راء منافس الرئيس بايدن لديه 20%
من الاصوات في الحزب الديمقراطي ولا
يعترفون بوجوده وهذا يعني خذل وعين
بالمجتمعات الديمقراطيه ولكن لنعود الى
الحزب
هذا صحيح بكل تاكيد في حقيقه الامر نعلموا
انك غالبيه الشعب الامريكي لا لا يرغبون
ان يروا
اعاده
للسجال بين دونالد ترامب والجون بايدن
ويبحثون عن وجوه جديده
وهذا الامر ياخذنا الى عهد كلينتون حيث
كان
الناخب الامريكي يرغب بتغيير عن ما عاشه
في فتره
وبعدها اوباما لكن
من غير الواضح حتى اللحظه كيف سوف تكون
هذه الوجوه الجديده سوف تتجلى لان ما نراه
مما يفعله بصفته رئيسا بانه كان يتمتع
بحسن حمائي
وقد مرت فتره رئاسته الاولى بطريقه كانت
مليئه بالاحداث خلافا لاي رئيس سابق اشكرك
من واشنطن الخبير في الشؤون الامريكيه
اريكهام ومن فلوريدا كنت معي توم حرب مدير
التحالف الامريكي الشرق اوسط شكرا لكما
اعلن الديوان الملكي الاردني منحى الانسه
رجوع ال سيف لقب الامير رجوى الحسين وذلك
بعد عقد قرانهما بل قيرانها على ولي عهد
الاردن الامير حسين بن عبد الله الثاني
وشهدت مراسم عقد القران في قصر زهران
بالعاصمه عمان حضور قاده وزعماء دول وضيوف
من كافه انحاء العالم
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه انتهت لم يبقى سوى التذكير
بابرز العناوين
السعوديه وامريكا
في السودان وتدوان الطرفيس على الالتزام
بجديه وقف النار
العربيه تدخل مطار الخرطوم وترصد حجم
الدمار الناتج عن الاشتباكات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع
حادث سقوط طويل الرئيس الامريكي خلال
مشاركته في حفل تخريج طلاب من القوات
الجويه يثير تكهنات حول صحته
وعشان تكشف عن وثائق مسربه تتحدث عن مخطط
روسي ايراني لطرد امريكا من سوريا
واوكرانيا تنقل الحرب الى بيل قرود اما
روسيا تحبط هجوما بريا لكاز على الحدود
واشنطن تكشف عن وثائق مسربه تتحدث عن مخطط
روسي
اشكر متابعتكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات